I have some bad news gene and I'm afraid
you'll have the wrong reaction okay
I'm not letting you go to work today
wait what you're just not ready son come
on working the cube as an emoji store
purpose in life everybody my age is
working on the phone except for me Oh
sweetie that's not true
[Music]
that's because I believe in you should
we wash our hands
[Laughter]
[Music]
what Center an emoji okay be cool
welcome to the secret world inside your
phone
we're emojis like me work and live here
each of us does one thing and we have to
nail it every time incoming text we are
go for men who me
[Music]
what is that I've got to get this phone
things this has never happened before
and now alex has made an appointment to
wipe out his phone
I'm not gonna run away from this I made
a mistake but I'm gonna fix it I think
we can make things right we just have to
go to a place where no emoji has gone
before the crowd I know we're short cut
throughs Matt but no one's ever left our
city and they'll send box after us
[Music]
what is this place the greatest place
ever I've never eaten another piece of
candy again high five don't do it
don't you do it it's already been in
there once you need to get the master
password access denied
this might take a while wait what access
tonight we're gonna have to dance our
way out everybody can dance
[Music]